the Comedy Central online series typical
Rick second season Asst premiere - this
past Monday the star of typical Rick
back here on the Rich Eisen show rockin
his scrambling Fran Vikings purple
t-shirt that's right nick swardson good
to see you sir good to see you Rachel
Zoe you're just that's an old school
t-shirt it is it was a gift it was very
lovely very lovely gift um yeah I got a
hold down the Viking somebody has to
good lord
come on that's just I'm just trying as
best as I can we have the Super Bowl
this year yes really huge deal i lock my
tickets in and yeah I hope I'm really
optimistic about this year I'm really
excited
Gavin cook is looking amazing I think
what abs is going to be great and I
think we're going to be better than
people think I think we're going to win
the North and the Super Bowl now you
like the saying I see what you did there
you went from you went from cautiously
optimistic to glowingly optimist me to
bat guano insane yeah that's basically
that that's how you that's correct
Calleigh did that escalated quickly to
use that for us that's how I live my
life rich every second I go from humble
to completely batten saying it's the
best way to live and no one's ready for
it well you know I mean you only know
one speed I understand that yeah exactly
I'm going home I'm so excited
opening day against the Saints AP's
return I know Monday Night Football
Night Football me and my buddy Josh
Duhamel is from North Dakota yeah the
North Dakota yeah he's a big bikes guy
and we're going we're really pumped I've
never asked you this or really anybody
else but are you gonna blow the jolly
horn when you go there I don't know I
hope cuz you know Josh's job have you
did you do it in the old stadium here I
didn't do it in the old city and I've
never done it - Josh do it yeah I think
he did what I think you did don't y'all
what yes blood I know you're coming back
on my seat you're going back but aging
Peterson in the and the first game
that's going to particularly and the
Saints - we hate hate the same hole from
a Roger
boy ya robbed us you know you did you
know you did the NFC Championship game
yeah it's going to be a nine yeah I
remember we were shooting Sandler movie
I think it was grownups too and no no it
was it was Reese it was on the Netflix
which it was ridiculous six and Taylor
Lautner it's friends with Sean Payton
he's a big lines fan he's a big line
seventies goodbye to Sean Payton he's
like hey Sean Payton's coming to set I'm
like great
and it's like Taylor Swift on he's like
he brought a bunch of sand scared
anybody wanted me and I was like good to
do and I'll I kind of made a scene then
Sam I was like you got to chill out man
it's something football season I was
like didn't care I don't ever seen
Sandler like get in like start screaming
at a sporting event like the thigh where
he loses it because I've been around him
for Yankee games and he gets
superstitious but he doesn't seem to be
one of those guys that goes totally
crazy he doesn't all I going it on time
toward you know Taylor Lautner yeah no I
like really lose it Sandler I've met the
most anyway I've seen him as Yankees
he's a big Yankee guy I've seen him flip
but I mean not cuz I like you didn't you
know what I mean but I've seen him like
yet I've seen him lose it but the
maddest I've ever seen Sandler is when
playing pick-up basketball he'll he'll
he'll lose it he'll get really upset now
who's it got Nick Swardson here on the
Richard show who is who is in this
pickup basketball game you Sandler who
else it depended I made the Spade play
no he's a fragile little child is made
of glass I couldn't even be like an
Isaiah Thomas type figure out there you
know undersized to use the phrase yeah
under sized very undersized he no he's
not he he plays like tennis kind of okay
but no he doesn't play hoop
Rob doesn't play hoop rock doesn't play
hoop so it's usually me and Sandler and
whoever we can grab I mean I was like
cool about just showing up to a court
and do it going rogue
like hey what are you doing if someone's
like what so like Brockman could be
playing ha ha yeah you just have to like
you got to know what you're doing you
know well what if somebody is pulled
into the game and they shoot too much
like somebody over there
oh it's been active doing really in
Chris Brockman I like to get my shots up
Nick what I get that do you make those
shots I do about 45 percent of time
45% of all shots from shots from the
field half-court skyhooks
100 P Oh 100 you just say a hundred
percent of those a hundred percent of
them yeah want you on my team that's
good to know
a mental note I've got a ringer for the
handler the red ass though he once got
kicked out of a league because he threw
it you kicked a basketball blue chip
style you threw a basketball and it's
healing one week and the next week I
threw it into the exit sign that's not
appropriate Oh school too so there are
children one day going to school without
an exit sign because shiho Hawk over
there
couldn't control his anger it was years
ago I'm much calmer now I drove that day
you would see you're on my team and now
you're off point too if you kick a ball
around salmon they'll kick your balls
into your own body now how looks about
nick swardson here on the on the Rich
Eisen show how are you how did you take
last night's walk-off loss in Chavez
Ravine to the Dodgers very rare twins
visit to here in Los Angeles for you to
be it for geographically sound visit by
your twins yeah I was you were there I
missed Monday and Tuesday excited shows
and so Wednesday we had lost money in
Tuesday we have it up both games just
not just came back and then Wednesday I
was like ok I thought I was going to
bring some mojo even though I was at the
twins angels game and this is on
instagram my instagram is at real Nick
Swardson I don't know if you've seen
this I recorded a video of pools up and
he was going for his 600th and it was
the bases were loaded against twins
course and I captured it in he hit a
grand slam and I was like livid
obviously so I was the last time I saw
the twins in California so I came back
Wednesday and we were up five to nothing
and we just totally blew it laughs at
the bottom of the 9th six five six five
yeah and I totally lost it on Instagram
again I made a video of it
just it's so frustrating it's so stacked
they're so good so I mean I should have
foreseen that but you think like five
nothing that's a pretty good question
you know you would and it was well the
worst part about it is you're stewing
about it and it how long did it take you
to get out of that parking lot last
night I stayed I liked what I just
stayed there and just sat in it just sat
in the mist of funk that was I was yeah
it was I hung out for a little bit and
then I thought it was gonna be like a
lot of Twins fans
so of course I'm dak ting I'm a hot
Jersey I'm a hat we weren't to know or
you go home have a blank Jersey for some
reason what are you doing that for I
don't know come on go monitor or Herbeck
or guy Eddie good a little guy Eddie
Lautner I mean good lord Taylor Lautner
give me a better yeah give me a
Pagliarulo if you just wanna go on over
there I know I grabbed some Jersey and
was blank it was super weird but uh okay
although there were gonna be a lot of
twins there and there was like wow man
would use a lot of Minnesotans in LA and
nobody showed up literally I saw like 10
people and Dodger games are I do respect
other games because they get really into
it Minnesota games Arnaz and like people
are just like are eight and well that
was a hit and like other stadiums people
get so fired up and I get fired up I did
one time I went to Target Field and I
was drinking and me and my buddies got
belligerent started yelling at AJ
Pierzynski hate that dude so we got him
on first base on one sec hey dial it
down that's too loud and then people
yelled at us for getting involved in the
game in the cackling well I mean to say
that I'm going to wake up today and I'm
going to get somewhat knackered and and
then shout obscenities at AJ Pierzynski
today that's that that might be counter
to what people go to Target Field
expecting didn't say obscenities see
what rich did what did she made me sound
like a crazy person and said I just said
well you got an f-bomb on the show about
five minutes ago so now I figured that
we were marking part I will not say the
word absolutely said the word is that
true I would say check the tape you i
mouthed
nobody without that I could have said
fart I did nice that's it
what did you say at AJ Pierzynski I was
like hey man I'm not a fan yeah nah
that's all I said all right yeah yeah I
just kept saying that I am sorry for
smearing you
that's the apology accepted will you for
the north from me in the north for you
in the north yes I let's take a break
with Nick Swardson we will come back and
we will talk about the NFC North and I'd
like to get some idea of what you think
the Super Bowl is going to look like
okay in your town all right then we'll
talk some some typical Rick as well on
Comedy Central's online series with Nick
Swardson back in sixty Seconds
[Music]
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show Nick
Swardson here typical Rick comedy
central's online series season 2 it
started this past Monday you get into
reddit AMA yesterday huh I did yeah
you're one of the people who do a reddit
AMA who I do believe don't mind being
asked anything yeah anything like you
don't mind now anytime I did one there's
a couple times I'm like you know I I I'm
really not up for being asked that you
know I mean well I mean you can pick and
choose well I know you can you know but
it's like yeah I mean some questions are
pretty rogue but uh yeah I mean I don't
ya
you look for anything you uh you
mentioned a print story too long to type
can you share right here it is it safe
for work um yeah I guess I could
condense it um I was in Las Vegas years
ago and I was at a some nightclub we
were in this VIP area and it was
upstairs overlooking the club I mean my
friends were drinking and one of my
friends is a little person and you know
we're all getting smashing and Prince
comes in and you know I was of course I
freaked out and everybody freaked out
but I'm from Minnesota so is a huge deal
and then he goes into this curtain doff
area you know everyone's like go say hi
to him like I was saying hi to Prince
I'm going to go into this like curtain
doff area so I just kind of stared it
like a weirdo and then my little person
friend Donny decided to go rogue which I
have that tattooed on my arm
it says Rosie up to go rogue yeah Donny
went rogue and went right into the
curtain just vanished we were like yeah
and uh he was gone for a while and we
were like what is happening and the
security guard comes somebody's like hey
man is that your friend in there and we
were fake yeah yeah maybe and then we're
like is everything cool in this area
like princes having like a blast with
him and then we were like huh I like
calm down
Donny just went rogue and had a blast
with Prince Pete for like an hour so why
wouldn't he say I've got some friends
who want to like he'd love it he's a
little jerk yeah you don't you tiny
don't you think like he could have said
yeah he did on the friends eat tog
Prince all to himself
what's the moral of that story Nick I
mean if you could choose what the moral
of that story is is a big friend yeah I
mean if I if I written doubt five
different morals of that story I don't
know if I would have cried my top five
well that's where we differ rich I like
the Vikings they're gonna win the north
and you think the Packers well we'll
always be that way do you know a lot
do you really deep down think Sam
Bradford can walk into Lambeau Field
chips down get things done because
that's what that's it's going to take
it's a Mario Kart no no he's one of
eleven he's one of 11 offensive riot
yeah yeah yes yes I do yes I do
yep yes I do
okay good the Jeff I do all right okay
yeah well good okay
thanks for coming are you are you fired
up about the Timberwolves after what
they did on on draft night get not to be
very alert you look really really good
yeah I'm excited for you
I'm really excited a lot of people have
been really excited about the Wolves
that aren't like from Minnesota
everyone's just soaked that they have a
good team you know
and it's really exciting now the Kyrie
element I keep hearing all those some
people keep sending me all these
articles and Twitter stuff you know
about Kyrie coming and how like Jimmy
Bell is really pushing for him and I
think it's cool I don't know what we
would have to lose for that and it's
weird because I like what we have right
now so it's tyrese amazed phenomenal
player obviously but I I kind of want to
see how we play it out with all these
young guys and now Jimmy Butler and
Teague and Ed so you know Crawford
joined - yeah I'm it was a great I
thought that was a neat sort of sixth
man I like that veteran presence - that
helped out with this whole gelling
process I thought that was a great
signing yeah and I said that in the
offseason I said what we need is a big
veteran signing we need like guys like
that who is been in that where did you
say that you say that - Donnie I said
that naked in my bathroom sadani
know I know that's what we need
you know I just watching the team I was
like I wish we had like back in the day
that like Sam Cassell or somebody just
come in and you know just just show
people what's up well it might be
Wiggins it might be Wiggins has to go
back to Cleveland for Kyrie and I
without a note of that that you can't
just blow that up you really just can't
I would think
although Kyrie karl-anthony towns and
Jimmy Butler is insane yeah I can go
into battle with that I mean you're
really really can but Kyrie you wait a
year or two with Wiggins Anthony towns
and and Butler now you're talking about
serious business
immunity I'll get Kyrie to come you can
get all that I know but you can't get
that now that's the problem
yeah I know so I'm you know we'll see
what happens but you know it's like if
we made grown ups three you know we
would have everybody and we would have a
foundation they're like do we want to
add Daniel day-lewis and you're like I
kind of do
he's phenomenal but we already have a
nice Center but maybe DDL will bring
maybe he'll come in and crush it just
what do we have to trade Schneider yeah
by the way Schneider for Daniel
day-lewis Wow
I mean that that's like that's like Babe
Ruth going to the Yankees yeah for a
song don't you be happy let's be honest
here we have to lose Norman meadows it
would have to be to have to lose a lot
easier a grown-up's trick not that I
know of no not that I know we are
Sandler and I are talking Santa has a
new idea for movie I can't talk about it
but we I hope it happens okay so with
hopefully next year I got a phone call
for you from somebody calling into the
show that's okay Matt and Tennessee you
put them up easy once to ask a question
of Nick Swardson here on the Richardson
show Matt you're on with Nick I think I
got to make it quick before getting
ready to die um if you actually had a
choice in a sport for a movie whether it
be serious or funny or whatever like
that and it was your choice of a type of
movie what would you do and what type of
a position would you play would you be a
head coach or you got together yeah
interesting
yeah thanks McCall man I appreciate that
what an interesting call now what do you
think he's really deep
trying to shape your career I think I
like that and that's a maker of dreams
he is a dream maker without a phone
charger I write I don't know if I'm at
Coach level yet but um I it's funny that
he said that because I did I am
developing this movie with a comedian
friend of mine Dwight Yorke in Minnesota
and where I play a NFL kicker not good
yeah and it's kind of serious but it's a
comedy but it's also dramatic elements
what's so Natick about it we have a seat
future seer called a yes he's the
nostris Nostradamus of yeah exports ins
mixture down let me Commodus mixture um
what is your sound say no just like so
the scent was serious about a kicker
just making making kicks is it is it
this is it the Blair Walsh project noted
oh my gosh that guy I still like looked
out my window I just I feel like in a
tree or something sweet Blair I wish
Blair the best he went to Seattle by the
way I don't know if he's going to make
that yeah it's Eisen hasta still there
no I thought Blair way over there where
Blair went there no houses out hit me up
on on typical Rick what do you got for
me here on this little Rick is awesome
it's the director of Grandma's Boy Nick
Goosen my co-star is Simon Rex aka Dirt
Nasty and it's funny this show was the
show that we pitched secondary we went
in the comedy central and we had mapped
out a really intense show with all these
layers and different seasons and they
were like now we're not really into that
and then I had thought of typical Rick
drunk when I was in a movie and I wrote
it down on a napkin and then I pitched
it to the network and they were like it
was like three sentences and I'm like
yeah I'll take six episodes it was
insane so it's basically a guy two guys
that moved to Hollywood I want to be a
dramatic actor and then my buddies just
along for the ride and he ends up
getting all the heat and attention Oh
inadvertently never and no matter how
much effort I put in she just keeps just
getting all this stuff just being like
Rick and just an idiot and getting high
and being a [ __ ] so in this movie where
you thought this up this movie theater
is do they serve alcohol did you yeah
that or did you tailgate before going
down now they serve Casa movie think I
just want to make sure I didn't just
come in hot every bread at Nick Swardson
on Twitter at real Nick Swardson on
Instagram and typical Rick on Comedy
Central's online series good to see you
again straight to see oh yeah Skol bike
and you'll come back we'll we'll revisit
this whole NFC North conversation
midstream yeah maybe I'll come back with
Tim out me and him are doing a movie
together this in a couple weeks done all
right cool
that's that's Nick Swardson here on the
record show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that video be sure to download our app
and I'll be sure to help the NFL figure
out what it catches